what causes that switch to flip the
overdrive
the full-on destroyer
it's the thing that allows you to go the
extra distance to dig just a little bit
deeper and push
a little harder get after it
so
when it doesn't make sense logical sense
to go on that's when you got to use your
emotion that's when you got to use that
anger that frustration that fear to push
yourself harder to push yourself to say
i don't stop
you gotta override that emotion with the
concrete logic
and willpower you fight the weak
emotions with the power of logic and you
fight the weakness of logic with the
power of emotions and in the balance of
those two that's where you find the
strength and the tenacity
to say to yourself
i
don't
stop